[Music]
welcome back everybody it is now time
for this week's pet project lori joins
us from the nspca and she brought along
someone who needs a safe and kind home
i hear this one is named kimchi right
yes rocky his name is kimchi and even if
you don't like the korean dish after
which he's named
uh this is the kimchi that everybody i
think will like and
if you can see i'm trying to get his
face in the camera he's got those
beautiful
eyes you know rocky that
the black cats the green eyes it's my
favorite one of my favorite color
combinations in cats
although we recommend that you find a
pet that matches your
personality and look for an animal with
the personality that you like well this
is still a gorgeous cat to bring into
your home and as you can see
he's really got a laid back cuddly
attitude
he's happy except for he does have
moderate kidney disease so
we are going to recommend a special diet
for kimchi here
he gets along with other cats he gets
along with
um older children we'd recommend family
so there's a lot of people watching
right now
that would love to have that kimchi
would be a great fit for their home and
their family
certainly a very handsome addition to
the family let's talk about fostering
kittens and dogs as well at the with the
nspca here it's a huge demand right now
yeah so rocky we're still in kitten
season we have a lot of orphan kittens
coming in off the streets and we need to
put them in foster care
before we can spend before they're old
enough to be span neutered and prepared
for adoption
but with the recent lifting of
restrictions in the pandemic and people
traveling
a lot of our foster parents aren't in
town right now so
nevada svc needs more people to open
their homes and their hearts
to fosters and if you are interested
please go to our website
at nevadaspcspca.org and put in an
application for foster care
and we really need your help right now
for these um precious lives
especially our kittens oh absolutely
lori thank you so much for everything
you guys do and obviously that is a
great way to find out if you like a pet
in your home so
definitely let's foster our local dogs
and cats
all right if you're interested in
adopting a pet go to nevadaspca.org
or just call them at 702-873-7722